committed to free speech and turning
straight talking and direct we may each
other hello and welcome to the plant a
teacher from Cardiff has been hailed as
the maths whisperer this week after his
entire class of thirty children
achieved an a star in their maths GCSE
after taking the exam six months early
well we thought it was about time
certain someone in the pledge class of
2020 up there debating games from
mediocre to top of the class so children
please welcome our very first guest
panelist he's gonna bring some
discipline to this rabble apparently now
Geoff used to be a teacher so hopefully
Nick he can help raise your debating
level and see - to a star although I'm
not holding out much hope to be fair
coming up on the show I'm loading it up
North June thinks Boris is finally
getting it right on Africa Geoff argues
the left need to accept that likes
aren't the same as votes and Afra is
serving off a slice of reality on
feminism but first it's Nick the more
observant among you have probably picked
up on the facts that I'm both white and
male what many of you probably don't
know is I attended a fee paying private
school now in the eyes of some this
instantly appears to disqualify me from
having an opinion on any matter
connected with or vaguely associated to
race this concepted nonsense was
superbly exposed by actor Laurence Fox
on TV last week when he derided the
notion Harry and Megan were forced to
leave the UK due to racism quotes we're
the most tolerant lovely country in
Europe he declared to
loud applause one audience member
chastised him an implied he didn't know
what he was talking about as he was a
privileged white male now agreed mr. Fox
won't have the same lived experiences as
anyone with a BA any background but the
utterly disdainful and cheap way his
remarks and those of many others can be
blithely dismissed is plain wrong is he
not allowed of you because he's white he
added the dangers of throwing racism
around can lead to police and other
authorities turning a blind eye to
appalling events such as the Manchester
Child grooming Stanton he could have
added rostrum Rochdale Telford and
Oxford to that grim tally to Nick I have
to say I'm quite impressed that you use
the term lived experiences shows you
have been listening to Apple and I on
occasion and okay on this one it's very
strange and I think that's where you're
gonna jump down my throat in a moment
I'm quite torn and I'll tell you why I
don't think the way the Lawrence Fox
presented himself helped and the way he
completely shouted down the audience
member was symbolic of many of the
issues that we talk about all the time
in relation to privilege and he couldn't
possibly know what it feels like to be a
person of color in a country that's what
it feels like to be a person of color in
a country where you are the minority
however I do think that when it comes to
the inclusion debate we have to figure
out what the narrative is in terms of
how we include white men into the
conversation because for this stuff to
be sustainable in Jeff you and I have
spoken about this one occasion for it to
be sustainable we have to figure out
what that conversation is and sometimes
what happens is we immediately jump down
the throats of anyone that voices this
kind of opinion and I don't necessarily
agree with it but I do believe
if we're gonna have something that's
sustainable in terms of inclusion we'd
better figure out what that conversation
is I definitely bring you in in a moment
Jeff on your debut but you indicated to
all zafar and I heard groaning about
because I was reading aloud I will come
to you in a minute yeah where to start
so I completely agree that it's
interesting and useful to hear what
someone like Lawrence Fox has to say I'm
not interested in no platforming or
shutting down someone like him I think
he is an incredibly revealing voice on
how privilege works because this is a
man who obviously doesn't understand
what racism is racism is not being
racist in the sense of sitting there
thinking hostile things about people of
color although maybe he does that I
don't know racism is a system and this
isn't about blaming white people this
isn't about saying you're white so you
are a problem this is about saying we've
all inherited a system that has
allocated opportunities and resources
unfairly and that's not the only system
class is another important system that
allocates resource on value so I think
the idea that this is kind of mutually
exclusive either you're interested in
race or you're interested in class and
that white working-class boys lose when
we talk about racial injustice it's a
complete fallacy these are all systems
that make our society unfair now I for
one am interested in how we change them
I don't see how somebody who is in
Lawrence Fox's position saying that he's
bored of race is any more helpful than
someone like me who's from a
middle-class background saying I'm bored
of class I don't think it's a problem
let's not talk about we should all
respect experiences that we haven't
lived that determine our outcomes now
what I have a problem with is that he
has shown a complete disinterest in
understanding the perspective of people
who have a different experience to him
and you say he's being shut down let's
be real the majority of the time on TV
on these platforms it is white men
shutting down people of color when we
talk about our experience I think the
problem problems is it comes from
essentially the liberal left which was
decided politics that when I was growing
up was always about don't use
pejoratives right don't stereotype by
age race sexuality or gender and then
it's suddenly also the wing of politics
this sort of going but what about these
are words straight white guys you know
so there is a
dog sale and I think that you know that
moment with Lawrence Fox day was seen to
be the start of a backlash against
what's called woke culture but was once
upon a song called snowflakes sjw's the
PC Brigade it and the goes like
rebrandings every so often and meals
from a personal point of view I I quite
like it because it has never been easier
it seemed controversial but I think that
saying you don't get to talk about this
it's not a great offer to the majority
of people and also you're simply on the
other side of the bay you've got some
black people saying I'm sick and tired
of explaining race so if you've got one
set of people that can't talk about here
and another set of people that don't
want to explain it where does it
understand he wasn't saying he wasn't
saying I'm not allowed to it wasn't that
people were saying he's not allowed to
talk about it he would think I'm bored
of it he was trying to shut down that
dialogue but the way that she said why
did she say why privilege was used to
shut him down she was said she said
you're not saying if you're white you're
not allowed to speak it's saying you
have inherited this system that has
benefited you how are you going to help
us dismantle it why it's important I'm
sure you've seen the clip when we're not
spots talks about beaming I perceive it
as he's being bored as just being called
a white privilege metal or white I think
he's bought with racism he's born with
that rather sure that what he meant and
and to be I'm not a white man obviously
but I do sometimes feel sorry for the
white men in society at the moment
because I feel like you're almost stuck
between a rock and a hard place if
you're a woman there's initiatives to
help you get on if you're a minority
there's initiatives to get help you get
on but sometimes I think that if you are
a middle class or middle-aged white man
then you're almost seen as the bad guy
in circumstances now and I don't believe
that Lawrence men I'm tired of a race I
think what he meant was things keep
getting blamed on racism what he was
saying is thing is that he didn't
believe were racists were been labeled
with that and this overuse of the label
racism had let and led to lots of things
like what Nick just mentioned the
Manchester the all
of those horrible situations that were
ignored for fear of sounding racist and
that is wrong well also just to pick up
on the privilege debate I think often we
sort of conflate the experience of all
white men let's be very clear the
experience of privileged white men as in
those from elite backgrounds like
Laura's what like a Lawrence Fox is very
different to the experience of white
working-class men and so I think what
we're talking about here is saying that
there are people and blue finish that
there are people in society that life is
just easier for because of the way the
system's has big no-no but you also have
to be open to the fact that you might
have blind spots ie I cannot comment on
the experience of a disabled person it's
not my experience so sometimes I had to
review on their lives I have to listen
to them when they tell me that this is
their experience because because I
haven't lived it
I literally may not happen to say we've
so overused the term a ban I know it
doesn't affect me and as Michelle points
out he's saying that we are we're
overusing racism we're labeling things
as racing when they're not based on what
based on his view that racism isn't
really a problem that he's noticed it's
doing relevant Jim next week the world
will quite rightly come to a halt to
remember the liberation of Auschwitz can
I only be anti-semitic upon Jewish no
precisely I'm actually involved in a
charity that tries to root out anything
is existing you know encompasses such a
large group of people that's why such a
small group that's try points it doesn't
distinguish my class it's just two words
white privilege it's like toxic
masculinity I always think how do these
things play out right if you're a 19
year old panel beater from we're getting
called Darren you're looking at you
think do I have do I have AI agent C so
so like you said in your opening gambit
it's about having more specific terms
because as they stand they're a bit too
poor so Jeff that's my point my point is
this is such a small group of society
and actually what we have is a system
that means that only a tiny group of
society actually get to fulfill their
potential encourages their just bring
some react some facts into this because
race and class are complicated but there
are facts that intersect so for example
and this is from David Lammy the black
MP who did review on race in the
criminal justice system there is greater
disproportionality in the number of
black people in prisons in the UK than
in the United States the country we all
like to say is much more racist than
ours these disproportionate numbers he
said represent wasted lives a source of
angry mistrust and a significant cost to
the taxpayer BMA individual space fires
including overt discrimination in parts
of the criminal justice system if you're
black
you'll treated more harshly than if
you're white and that often applies to
working-class people because the
majority of the people in the criminal
justice system are working-class and
another fact as well job applicants from
white sounding names and that's a crude
term deliberately are 74 percent more
likely to have success than applicants
from ethnic minorities with identical
Seavey's that is names that the people
receiving the application so you're not
as white why my last name is certainly
sounds why it's a Jewish name but my
first name is very obviously Africa
sentiment the people and I went on the
streets and asked homeless white people
do you feel privileged they're just
gonna laugh in my face and I think
that's to me what Lawrence is frustrated
against this whole generalization
suppose white men no the generalization
based on skin color anywhere this could
rumble on and on